1 2 3 1 2 3 les tristes ce gamin là là
là
quoi tu parle pas il me l'a dit ses
parents sont décédés quand il avait deux
ans tout ce que je sais c'est qu'ils
étaient présents quand c'est arrivé
trois gardes du tout là haut
elle est là ta mère dans les eaux
troubles de ta mémoire et avec quoi on
les a pas tu es souvenirs avec ça
j'oubliais c'est pas gratuit il faut
bien vivre un peu d'amour un peu de
miers humble de soleil les souvenirs
j'aime ça la musique c'est ce qu'il faut
on dirait qu'il va parler ballon mon
p'tit père tu en as mis du temps tu l'as
vu ta mère c'est que quand elle te poses
des questions tête au marché mais qu'est
ce qu'il est arrivé il ya quelques
effets secondaires mais l'un dans
l'autre ça vaut le voyage ou s'est
jamais comporté comme ça tu fais c'est
lors de soupers c'est pas la mort qui
l'empêchent de vivre ce gamin ou tourner
en rond si on fait rien il aura deux ans
toute sa vie n'a pas fait de santé votre
garçon et les légumes une sorte de
représentant
présentement les qu'humain
je peux vérifier s'il vous plaît les
mauvais souvenirs
fall est noyé sous des flots de petits
bonheurs c'est tout ce que je te
souhaite et c'est à toi d'ouvrir le
robinet nacelle
pour moi
le sou
c'est pas
il est plus
on a
tu veux conseil et avec les femmes je
n'ai pas